uh okay so uh i guess we should uh we
should get started right um
it is uh it is 9 30 maybe a few more
people join us um
in time
uh so let me start by introducing
the session just quickly so welcome
everybody to the distributed computing
session of itcs
and um i don't want to spoil the talks
by telling you what each of the papers
is about but i do want to remark on one
thing that i think is really nice about
this session
it shows the breadth
of the distributed computing
field
it shows the various models that we like
to study we have here papers
in
distributed network algorithms in
massively parallel computing in shared
memory
and
we also have
some of the really nice connections to
various areas in math
that we like to make in this field and
there's some very nice representation of
that
in this session from graph theory
to
topology and descriptive combinatorics
and i think that this is one of the
things that distinguishes
uh our field this kind of breadth of
areas that we touch upon
so without much ado uh let us get
started and yannick is going to be the
first speaker so i'm going to stop
sharing
and yannick you can share your screen
yes
i will
it works yes you can see everything
so let me start yes so my name is
yannick mouse and i will present our
paper distributed vertex cover
reconfiguration so this is joint work
with current sensor hillel
roman pellet and tigran tonion
and i won't tell you so much about the
distributor and about the model actually
but mostly about the problem that we
studied here so as you can see we want
to go from one vertex cover to another
one
but let's start with some motivation
so just assume you have some network
and you want to monitor all the links
so maybe you've identified a set of
machines which do that for you but now
there's some maintenance needed and you
need to change to a different set of
machines
so you need to change
the monitoring machines what you want to
do here now is while you do the change
you always want to still monitor all
links even during the change so you
basically want to have a smooth
transition here between the
two situations
each of these situations monitoring all
links and that can easily be seen as
just the vertex cover so the subset of
the node nodes that touches
all edges
we'll focus on the transition
and this is a classic problem which has
been
studied and
normally this is called sequential in a
sequential setting the vertex cavalry
configuration problem here you have two
vertex covers so alpha and beta the blue
and the green one and the goal is to
transform one into the other which means
you're supposed to give a
reconfiguration schedule that is just a
sequence of vertex covers
so each of these
ci's here is a vertex cover this ensures
that even in between you monitor all
links
and you're allowed to change one vertex
at a time in the classic setting so you
can maybe add the green vertex here
then remove one of the blue ones
then add another one
here remove one and so on
until you've arrived at your
uh
green vertex cover
there are two parameters which are
important and tell you about the quality
of your schedule one is the length
but if you
restrict yourself to monotone schedules
where you can only change each vertex
once and this is what we do in this
paper the length and sequential setting
is always the symmetric difference
between the two vertex covers
the other parameter is the cost
what's the size of
the largest size of one of these
intermediate vertex covers
classic question that has been asked
before is
can you even find such a reconfiguration
you have to go from one
vertex cover to another one
with a certain costs
and this is a difficult problem in
general it's even piece based complete
and even on
you know some restricted graph classes
that remains a hard problem
but there are some exceptions so some
problems
you can actually reconfigure
pretty cheaply
in centralized world
so
this is what has been known before and
what has been done in the classic
setting but this paper is not about the
sequential reconfiguration problem
instead we do what we do is motivated by
the distributed setting
so in the distributed setting you have
such a large network many of these
computers and now you don't want to just
change one vertex at a time because
there's no global entity controlling
this whole network you don't even know
how
nodes which are very far away can
control the action decides who adds
which vertex first but instead you want
to change many of the vertices at the
same time maybe add two
[Music]
nodes to the vertex cloud which are far
apart remove some so you want to get
some parallelism here and this is what
we call
batch reconfiguration
so let's look at a
at the definition so first an incomplete
definition so
the only change from before is just that
we
remove the restrictions that you can
only change one vertex but we just
yeah you can change many vertices
but now
this causes problems you could just
go from one vertex cover to the other
one in just one step one batch and
you're done
but what does actually happen here so
you put all
these vertices all these changes into
one batch
so some of these
leave the vertex cover
some other ones appear
so all of them are in one batch but if
you really want to run this on a system
this is not an atomic action to really
like do the whole batch that whole batch
has a change so actually there is some
asynchronous implementation of this
so we as a designer who just put all
these vertices into one batch have no
control on the order inside a
and now what could happen if we just go
from one vertex cover to the other one
if we look at an edge here
both of these are in the same batch
normally we would first add the green
one
but now it could happen that first the
blue one leaves in this
asynchronous implementation and then one
edge is not my target anymore
we don't want to have that
another issue that can happen is
that
the order could be that first all the
green ones
are added and we don't have a problem
with monitoring
any of the edges so first all the green
ones are added and the blue ones are
removed
but now we in between had a very very
large vertex error
and we also want to avoid that
this is why we ask our batch
reconfiguration schedulers
to be robust
so
what we want to do here we want to have
batch reconfiguration schedule so you
can reconfigure as many vertices as you
want unbounded number at the same time
but you need to have the robustness
regardless in which order a batch is
executed
you always want to monitor all the links
this is uh technically you can
equivalently you can formulate it as
it's written down here and you also need
to pay for the worst case cost
if an adversary really
implements your batch in a bad order and
this boils down to this condition down
here
so this is the problem that we study and
this is actually so far like it was
motivated by distributed but it's a
problem that is interesting
in the centralized world it's
interesting in the distributed world and
you can study it in any setting that you
like and we also
do this and we have quite
a large number of results and i'll just
give a very
quick
overview on some of them because i won't
be able to go into depth here so one is
that we can
have a generic method to take a
sequential schedule and create a batch
one
uh just with a little
epsilon factor
loss in the cost
per upside on depends on how many
batches do you have and this is also
optimal you cannot improve this
then we for certain graph classes have
new sequential schedules and also new
batch schedules
and unify some of the proofs for already
known sequential schedules and many of
these results come with lower bounds not
all of them
and we in the sequential world we have
some very short
batch schedules where we just use four
lectures for certain graph classes
but then we also have results on the
distributed side that was our initial
motivation where we came from
and they're also on certain graph
classes
we can compute them very fast mainly in
lock star
rounds
and we can compute them optimally the
runtime cannot be improved the
approximation factor cannot be improved
most of these results come with lower
bounds the main tool here
but this is what we call a small
separator decomposition which is
inspired by network decompositions and
padded partitions but is slightly
different and might be of interest
for other problems
and
what i like about this
i'll talk a bit more about this in the
long talk is that actually using such a
decomposition somehow the goal here is
to make different parts of the graph
independent
but actually it turns out for
approximation problems it's not so easy
to then just deal with these parts
independently
and yeah i invite you to
have a look at the longer talk to see
more details on this so let me not talk
about these other results but just
thank you here and
maybe say
just as an open question
all of this here talks about monotone
schedules
and i would really like to know
what happens in the sequential world in
the centralized world in the distributed
world what happens if you don't have
that and i don't know
thank you very much
so
happy thank you so much
yeah we have time for questions
uh so can i have a question uh do you
think you can define this small
separator decomposition
um is it easy uh
yes
basically
okay maybe i even have it on the slide
somewhere
so maybe then it's easier to follow
so basically
you just have these clusters of small
diameter
and you have this
these yellow nodes here
which have a in total a large small
cardinality so we have few of these
nodes and
for every edge
it should either be inside one of these
clusters or have one endpoint here so
really like for the
it's the intuition here basically for
this vertex discovery configuration
problem is if you add all the yellow
ones the vertex cover
then all these
edges that leave the cluster are covered
so yeah this is basically
so such a very good question so this x
so should i think of it as that it is
smaller than like a constant fraction
[Music]
um
it really depends on the graph class and
where we apply it so it really can be
very very different depending on what
you want to have yes it it might be a
constant fraction of the notes but it
might be even an absolute small number
okay right or like it should relate
actually to the
like
really it really depends on where you
apply it where you want to apply it and
for this vertex cover reconfiguration
problem here you really want this x to
be
small in terms of
the symmetric difference between your
vertex colors
because this basically tells you what
opt is
and it should be small in terms of
the optimal cost that you need to pay
because you will more or less add all of
these yellow vertices here to the vertex
cover in between
so it should be small in comparison to
your opt depending on which problem you
study opt is something different and
this is actually something which you
really use that in certain sense it's
not just
a constant fraction of the vertices
so
depending on which problem you study
you should pick the right x
okay
let's move on to the next talk uh thanks
a lot yannick
so
the next talk will be by quan quan can
you share your sights
and a mute
which i always forget
sure let me share my slides
awesome
good
hi uh hi everyone my name is congress
and today i'll be talking about work on
near-optimal distributed implementations
of dynamic algorithms for symmetry
breaking problems
this is joint work with shiri antaki and
shai solomon at tel aviv university and
for this short presentation i'll mainly
focus on the motivation models and
challenges
to give some
very broad motivation for our work real
world networks are often dynamically
changing with new edges being inserted
and deleted every second
we show some examples of publicly
available data sets which have millions
to even more than 100 billion edges
and
private graphs could be even larger up
to trillions of edges
social networks in particular hosts new
connections every second and on such
large graphs with billions of edges even
linear time static algorithms are too
expensive to be re-run many times as the
graph changes
and this then naturally motivates the
study of dynamic algorithms which are
traditionally studied in the sequential
centralized setting
unlike static algorithms uh dynamic
algorithms we compute part of the
solution after each update
instead of recomputing the entire
solution
and the quality measure we care about
for dynamic algorithms is the update
time and the goal is to minimize this
update time
one nice aspect of the sequential
centralized model which is the model
that traditional dynamic graph
algorithms are studied in
is that we can access all the vertices
on one machine
however on graphs with billions or
trillions of edges the graphs are too
large and it takes too much time to
compute sequentially on one machine
and so naturally the focus of the
session is of course
the next step is to split the graph
among many different processors or
machines where each node is a processor
or a machine and edges are the
communication links between the machines
nodes can send messages to each other
via the edges and in this paper we
consider the multicast model
where nodes can choose to send the same
or different messages to some or all of
the nodes
nodes can also use multiple rounds of
communication to send the messages
where in each round they can send
messages to the same or different
neighbors
the message complexity of a distributed
algorithm is the number of messages sent
in total over the course of the
algorithm and in this paper we focus on
the congest model where messages have
all login
size
a problem with sending too many messages
is that they can overwhelm the network
bandwidth and i'll take talk a bit more
about this uh later on
uh another complexity measure we care
about of course is the round complexity
which is uh traditionally studied in
distributed literature and is defined as
the number of rounds the algorithm uses
uh one problem again with having too
many rounds is that it takes too long
for the algorithm to compute the
solution and it can also result in the
algorithm sending too many messages
distributed networks can also be dynamic
where edges are added and deleted from
the network and such dynamic changes
also changes the communication topology
of the network
so given these definitions
on these dynamic distributed networks
the grand prize for dynamic distributed
algorithms we seek to obtain
is to have message complexity that
matches the update time of the best
known sequential centralized algorithm
while also maintaining all of one round
complexity
and what's even better is
for our algorithms to
achieve a robustness against adaptive
adversaries and this is a characteristic
we achieve for our algorithms in this
paper
so dynamic algorithms are naturally
robust against adaptive adversaries and
all of the algorithms presented in our
paper are
deterministic
a number of previous works have studied
dynamic distributed algorithms but most
have focused on minimizing round
complexity
and some very recent works have also
studied simultaneously handling many
concurrent updates
however
the algorithms in these previous works
operate by sending messages to all their
neighbors via broadcasts
this means that the number of messages
required by these algorithms is at least
omega of delta where delta is the
maximum degree in the graph
and for sparse graphs the number of
messages sent could be as large as omega
m
for sparse graphs where m is the number
of edges in the entire graph
perhaps surprisingly
very few previous works consider the
number of messages sent by the algorithm
after dynamic updates as a complexity
measure to minimize
there are many practical real-world
situations where few messages may be
required
uh some examples include systems with
poor wireless connections
over-saturated networks where many
independent agents are on the same
network or a mobile data network in a
poorly connected area
our work focuses on using multicasts for
nodes to send messages to a specific
subset of neighbors not all of the
neighbors
a few works have studied message
complexity but only for certain problems
asadi onak shiber and solomon gave an
algorithm for mis
leg and solomon study oneplus epsilon
maximum cardinality matching
in terms of a graph property called
arboricity denoted by alpha
where alpha could be as large as square
root of m in general graphs
and finally kaplan and solomon gave a
low out degree orientation algorithm for
specifically constant alpha
one natural starting point for
developing these um
dynamic distributed algorithms is to
adapt centralized dynamic algorithms to
the distributed setting but there are a
number of challenges for adapting these
centralized dynamic graph algorithms
first it is difficult for all nodes to
determine the number of edges in the
graph if updates on disconnected
components of the graph occur
so recall that the edges are also
communication links so there's no way
for two disconnected components to talk
to each other
and many centralized algorithms use the
number of edges in the entire graph as a
parameter
second many centralized algorithms
perform global restarts where a big
portion of the graph recomputes some
information
such a global restart in this
distributed setting will mean that
information will be propagated
throughout much of the network
which could result in both high round
and also high message complexity
so while a goal will restart may not
reach every single node in the network
it could still take omega of the
diameter number of rounds
and the solution to these challenges is
to consider
information from the partial local
neighborhood not the entire graph
so using the local neighborhood reduces
the round complexity
and using a portion of the local
neighborhood or only a partial local
neighborhood reduces the message
complexity
so using this intuition we study a
number of symmetry breaking graph
problems in our paper
including delta plus one coloring
maximal matching three halves
approximate maximum matching and maximal
independent set
and our algorithms achieve this grand
prize up to polylog n factors
so here's um a summary of
a number of results in our paper
for these problems
and our message complexity matches the
update time for these problems up to
polylogin factors
some of them exactly
and you can refer to our longer talk in
our paper for specific details about
these algorithms
and i want to spend the last couple of
minutes talking more about mis
about one minute left just to let you
know yeah
thanks
um
and just to give a quick overview on mis
as i mentioned previously uh
asadi ona shibura and solomon provide a
deterministic dynamic distributed mis
algorithm their algorithm uses m to the
three fourth amortized vestiges and of
one amortized realms
but their algorithm uses one crucial
characteristic of the graph which is
that the graph remains connected
throughout all the updates
so compared to our
results we improve the message
complexity polynomially while only
paying a polylog and factor in the
number of rounds
and most importantly we obtain a result
without using any connectivity
assumptions
and the starting point of this result
builds upon the sequential centralized
dynamic mis algorithm of glutathione con
and just very quickly the group tile and
con algorithm prioritizes membership in
the mis to low degree notes
which means that low degree notes are
added to the mis first before adding
high degree notes high degree nodes are
only added to mis after processing the
low degree nodes
and
the main part of the gupta and con
algorithm is that they do a global
restart on all the high degree notes
after each update step to determine
which update uh which high degree nodes
to add to the graph
so
there's naturally a couple of challenges
for distributing this algorithm the
first challenge is how do you determine
the high degree and no degree nodes if
the number of edges in the graph is
unknown
the second challenge is how do we
perform a global
restart efficiently and the solution to
the second challenge is that instead of
a global restart we instead do a local
restart and i encourage you to watch our
longer talk for how specifically we
solve these challenges
and i just want to conclude with um
we
initialize a formal study of message
efficient dynamic algorithms in
distributed network and we achieved this
grand prize for several fundamental
graph problems up to polylogin factors
there are a number of interesting
questions there are that is a result of
our study and we think this these
questions will be interesting to explore
in future work um so this concludes the
presentation i'm happy to take any
questions if there's still time left
thanks a lot um i think uh while uh the
next speaker sets up uh hebrew uh we we
can take a quick question if anyone has
one
now you would you want to share your
slides
yes
okay all right thanks a lot
thank you
um can you hear me
yeah definitely
okay
so hello everyone and thank you for
attending
so first of all i will talk about the
distributed systems model that we are
considering we are considering a finite
set of processes
with a communication model of shared
memory this means that each process has
its own memory slot to which it can
write but they can read the whole shared
memory and we are allowing processes to
crash
this means that processes can stop their
execution at any time and they will
never recover from this crash
and we are considering asynchronous
weight-free
a distributed models which means that
each process runs at its own time
and it does not need
the other processes to progress in order
to do work
in particular we are interested in task
solvability so for example consensus
approximate agreement among other tasks
i will talk a bit about a combinatorial
topology so i will start with simplices
so simplices are simply
multi-dimensional triangles that are
defined by a finite set
of vertices
and
we can glue together this simply says to
form more elaborate structures called
simplicial complexes
an interesting thing is that if we
interpret simplices as a finely
generated spaces then we have a
geometric
interpretation for the whole simplicial
complex
and now i will go into the topological
modeling of distributed systems so the
idea is that we want to construct a
simplicial complex from the distributed
system model in order to be able to
express non-trivial features as
topological properties and the way
that we do it is that
we use local states to define vertices
we use global states to define
faces and we use the
indistinguishability relation between
these global states
to decide how the faces intersect
so to show an example here is a two
process weight free shared memory
model so there are basically three three
different possibilities either the green
process is faster
which is this one that i'm highlighting
or the red process is faster which is
highlighted here or both
are more more or less at execute at the
same time which is this
execution as you can notice the
execution where the green process is
faster
is indistinguishable for the execution
where both execute at more or less the
same time for the red process because
the red process cannot tell
or not whether the green process has
received its input value
and therefore they are connected
by this red
red vertex
so in order to capture how the
communication transforms
a distributed system we use a sequence
of simplicial complexes which we call
the protocol complex p0 p1 up to
pk one per round
and the idea is that coming that
communication transforms the k round
protocol complex into the k plus one
protocol complex and an interesting
property is that in the weight-free
shared memory model in particular in the
iterated immediate snapshot model which
we are using each communication round
basically subdivides
the input complex
so to take a look to what that means so
here is an example of a three process a
weight free shared memory protocol
complex this is the
protocol complex at round zero so at
round zero no process has communicated
and they are only aware of their own
input values which is represented by
this simplex
however after one round of communication
there are many more different
possibilities
you can see that the vertices in the
corners
correspond to processes that were very
fast and therefore they were not able to
learn any input from any other processes
meanwhile the processes that are in the
middle are processes that were able
to learn all of the input values from
all of the other processes and the rest
like these two correspond to processes
in executions that were able to learn
only one of the input values
so
this is captured more precisely by the
asynchronous computability theorem which
that is due to helichia and chaby
which
is a characterization of asynchronous
shared memory computability in terms
of chromatic subdivision and the
existence of
simplicial maps that preserve the
validity conditions established by delta
so
i'm ready now to talk about our
contributions in our paper so we define
continuous tasks and chromatic functions
then we show that chromatic functions
have a
version of a chromatic version of this
inclusion approximation theory
which then allows us to give a complete
characterization of the weight-free
con
task solvability in terms of
continuity and color preservation
properties
and as an extra we have that we can use
a continuous task to specify
density requirements
so
the asynchronous computability theorem
matches task solvability to simplicial
maps and subdivisions
and at the same time this impression
approximation theorem matches continuous
function to subdivision and simplicial
maps so a natural question that one can
ask is whether or not we can tie these
two together and match a task
solvability to continuous functions
and the answer is yes but the continuity
condition is not enough
and why well
take a look at the hourglass task shown
here the hourglass task is not solvable
in weight-free shared memory
however there is a continuous function
that matches the validity condition
delta
so what is happening here well
we should notice that any continuous a
function that matches the validity
condition delta doesn't preserve the
color structure and also any simplicial
map
that preserves the validity condition
delta also must collapse part of the
simplicial complex like it is shown in
this picture these
vertices will be collapsed into this
single vertex
so in order to overcome these obstacles
we give a definition that restricts the
behavior of continuous function
which is and this is the formal
definition but basically this ensures
that a function does not collapse and it
forces it to respect the color structure
the nice thing about this condition is
that
any function that
satisfies this condition has a chromatic
approximation and then later we show
that these functions that have a
chromatic as a approximation match
exactly tasks that are solvable in the
asynchronous weight-free shared memory
model
so i will give a
brief visual sketch of the of the proof
of the
a chromatic approximation so the idea is
to subdivide the input complex until
simplices are very small and we can and
we can guarantee that they fall inside
of a star at the image we can do this
via the layback number uh theorem
and then once we guarantee that then we
look at the
center of the star and we match
the vertex of the corresponding color
which in this case is the yellow vertex
and we map it to the center of the star
we do this because then this allows us
to project and get rid of one color
like like here in this picture
and
because we can get rid of one color then
we can project and this reduces the
dimension of both the input complex and
the output complex and this enables us
to apply induction
and repeat the same operation over and
over again until we have a very simple
problem to solve
and then
we can use the lower dimensional
solutions
to have higher dimensional solutions
just by keeping track of
which were the vertices that were mapped
in the centers of the stars
and at the end we joined all of these
partial solutions to build a global
approximation
so in conclusion
in the paper we showed that task
solvability in the weight research
memory model is essentially a
topological and a color preserving
property
and we can use these chromatic functions
to define continuous tasks because
continuous tasks are now one-to-one
match to
the tasks that are solvable in
grade-free shared memory
and also chromatic functions are exactly
the functions that allow a chromatic
simplicial approximation and we also
explain this correspondence and one
extra thing that we can find in the
paper is is an interesting
application which is that we can use a
continuous tasks to specify for the
requirements so for example the thing
that i was mentioning before about
density is that for example approximate
agreement we can specify an approximate
agreement
which results in at least 99
or any
percentage that we want that will result
in exact agreement
so um that is all and thank you very
much
do you have any questions
yeah we do have time for uh some
questions
yes
so what do you think that uh your work
leaves open
in this arena
so
so i think that the what what is opening
in
[Music]
what is left open is whether or not we
can also use
these continuous functions to other uh
system to other distributed system
models
so for example in the
once one strong assumption in the
weight frequent memory model is is the
assumption that the systems have a
comp that they have compact
communication models so this means that
they there is a fixed round by which
they will
by which all processes must decide this
is because of the
weight freedom however there are many uh
models that do not have this
compact property this compactness
property
and
he here
it's um
we are in a way thinking that there will
always be a fixed round and
we want to extend this to in that
direction and also we want to think
about uh
streaming protocols so
or stabilization protocols so
maybe we we want to to think about
not only having an input and having an
output but having some
also some eventuality condition and
other properties
very interesting
all right let's uh move on let's thank
you for the
talk
and uh move on to the next talk which
will be by watching so
oh great
hello everybody can you hear your name
we can hear you but it was better before
uh when we were talking with the session
i don't know what you changed
uh is it not better
yeah it became better again okay yeah
sorry
yeah so if it become verse again then
please tell me
um yeah so hello everybody so i i will
try to keep my talk short so
let me jump to the summary
um okay so
uh you know in computer science and
distributed algorithms we have all of
those models that we study right and one
of those simple models is the so-called
model of distributed computing
and then there is this field in infinite
mathematics called descriptive
combinatorics where mathematicians study
certain local constructions so to say
so kind of this both of these fields
study local construction so there could
be some kind of connection between them
and it turns out that indeed there is a
connection there are some i would say
pretty interesting connection between
these two fields and we are not the
first ones to
to
basically um come up with this idea so
uh anton bernstein came up with this
idea and in this paper we basically try
to push these ideas further
so i need to quickly start by defining
this focal model of computing right so
this is a very old distributed model
very simple so we just have this huge
undirected graph on unknowns we think of
each node as being a computer and now to
make things super simple we just assume
that the computers are communicating in
synchronous message bouncing grounds the
messages can be unbounded also the
computation that happens inside the
computers is unbounded so everything is
very simple at the beginning of the
algorithm the computers know only some
basic information like
how many nodes there are and in the end
everybody should know it's part of the
output for example if you want to color
the network everybody should know its
color
and the time complexity again very
simple it's just the number of rounds
so in this talk we will actually make
things even much more simpler we will
just talk about graphs that have
constant degree and they are actually
just regular trees okay so everything's
super simple it actually it makes sense
to consider this class of regular trees
because this class is already only
captures a lot of the difficulties in
this locomotive
so the cool stuff about the encore model
is that we actually know a lot okay so
that was like really a lot of progress
in the past 10 years
and for example here is one thing that
we understand so if you really restrict
yourself to these delta regulators and
if you also restrict yourself to a large
class of problems that we call problems
like these examples then we actually
understand that all those problems are
in one of the five buckets each problem
is one of the five types which i think
is really amazing so for example we know
that like one bucket are problems that
you can solve in logan rounds either
deterministic or a condominium
another bucket low block and randomized
rounds but logan deterministic and so on
so i think this is really amazing
because for example if you tell me that
you have an algorithm for your favorite
local problem that runs in lock square
block square around then i can
automatically tell you okay but i have
faster algorithm that needs only loading
rounds
okay so we really understand a lot
okay
so okay now for something completely
different
so what is this descriptive
combinatorics i just want to give you an
example
so so here is a regular i give you a
square sheet of paper
and scissors
and i ask you to
cut the square
into into some pieces
and then just rearrange these pieces
just basically shift them
so that they form a circle of the same
area i mean this is clearly impossible
right if these pieces are somehow enough
behaved and this just has to be
impossible right but what if the pieces
are measurable so measurable is somehow
like one of the basic conditions one of
the basic notions that people enough
study right
so actually it turns out quite
surprisingly that then the answer is yes
that you can really kind of cut
uh cut the square into something like 10
to the i don't know
300 or something pieces
and each of these pieces will be really
something super complicated right
and then you just shift these pieces and
you get a circle
and somehow the way how how
mathematicians constructed this thing
is actually using some kind of local
constructions inside
they are actually kind of reducing it to
some kind of matching or fall problem
and it turns out that somehow these type
of constructions are actually pretty
similar to this
distributed local model that we are
studying and this is exactly what is
descriptive combinatorics is
about so now i will kind of jump to
uh kind of the main point of the paper
or kind of what is our contribution so
we basically try to study these things
like you know complexity theory but you
know in the local model i already told
you that we now understand that we have
these five complexity classes
and we understand that every problem is
in one of these five buckets
right but also in this descriptive
combinatorics you can have some like
pretty natural definitions you can
you can want to construct so called
moral solutions for measurable solutions
i mean it's it's defined totally
differently than distributed computing
these are like some very abstract
definitions but these are you know
really some well well studied
well-defined complexity classes but by
the way there is also this field of
factors of ids i i don't want to talk
about it now to keep things kind of
simple
so so basically what we try to do is we
try to do what people in complexity
theory are doing right we just try to
define as many classes as we can
and then to prove as many inclusions as
we can right
so so this is somehow like the picture
of what we are trying to do so also in
the paper we introduced some new tricks
that were already again used in the in
some subsequent words works to get some
new results both in the field of
distributed uh algorithms and
descriptive combinatorics but there is
no time to go over this thing
so let me just try to conclude so it
feels that
this is really an exciting area and
there is a lot of things waiting to be
discovered
and i hope that i kind of cultivate at
least part of my excitement about this
whole thing
and also big thanks to rotten for
sharing this session uh and mark for
organizing and all of the other
organizers
thank you
uh thanks a lot uh we have a few more
minutes and i wonder if you um if it's
possible you know it's a very deep paper
but i wonder if it's possible to say
something a bit more concrete about the
the kind of results that you get
okay yeah so so thank you so i will i
can for example go to this picture right
uh so i i can just you know give you an
example of an arrow from the paper right
so for example here is an arrow that has
actually two collections
so so it is actually proving that this
class of
logan these are all the problems that
you can solve with a local algorithm
with logan rounds either distributed or
randomized or sorry either deterministic
or otherwise so this class is actually
exactly the same as this class of
so-called bare measurable solutions
so you know this is kind of an
very abstract class i i'm sorry that
there is no way i can kind of define
these things one of the reasons is that
i i i actually frankly don't understand
like that much these formal definitions
somehow when we work with it we usually
have some kind of
also for example when we work with this
class we actually have some kind of
combinatorial understanding of what are
kind of the constructions that you can
do in these classes okay so somehow you
know these things they are defined very
abstractly but when you work with them
then oftentimes you have some kind of
combinatorial values of understanding
them
so so i think for example this is
something that i find
very surprising
for several reasons one of the reason is
that really you kind of get the equality
of classes right you have this concept
that you can define in distributed
algorithms
this overflow again it feels kind of
arbitrary right i mean while again why
not something different
and this thing it it actually this is
something that talks about infinite
graphs so i i didn't want to go into
details but all of these things they
talk about infinite graphs which talks
about infinite trees
and there is no
way of measuring something as function
of n because there is no difference in
it so i i kind of feel like that it's
really interesting that it kind of
matches right
so i try to talk a bit more exactly
about this thing in the in the longer
version of the video
so maybe the best i can say is you have
to maybe try to look there
[Music]
yeah thanks a lot i appreciate that
doing this in 10 minutes is a mission
impossible
uh does anybody have another question
maybe in the one minutes that we have
left for the talk
yeah
i wonder if you could say something
about
what would require to go beyond trees
yeah
yeah so for example we have also for
example another paper that tries to
study again grits like very very simple
graph right
uh like you know think of like two
degrees or something like that so so
this is again very simple graph but
actually things are behaving quite
differently
we again kind of draw draw a picture
where we have all of these classes but
now the arrows are actually a bit
different so so that there are still
some interesting things you can prove
but some of them are actually different
so
uh yes also basically currently
we we understand i i would say quite
well these like very concrete things
like with trees or grids and we have
some general understanding of general
grass i mean when we talk about grassy
always constant degree graph which is
already kind of a big restriction i
guess if you for example care about
distributed algorithms
but
there is something for for constant
degree for for all constant degree
graphs for example we understand that
this is just an example that this class
here is always subset of this class here
uh actually this this equality of
rockstar and it will continue this holds
very generally this is like a very
general phenomenon so we understand that
some things are like very general
phenomena but currently i i feel like it
kind of makes sense to really look at
these like very simple examples like
trees they are the expanding graphs
grits these are the graphs of small
growth
and and even there it feels like that
there is lots that we don't understand
so thank you for the question that's
very good
okay thanks a lot uh so let's go to the
last talk of the session which will be
by mobina and this is going to be a
again something completely different
from the most abstract paper in the
session to one of the most uh practical
contributions that we have today
hey can everyone see my screen
okay
so yeah my name is marina and i'll be
talking about adaptively adaptive
massively parallel constant round tree
contraction
so uh tree contractions are very general
tools for solving a wide range of
problems on trees
the idea is basically you take
components of your tree and contract
them into vertices and you do this
iteratively until t itself is a single
vertex
now this process must exhibit some
properties first of all the contraction
must be efficient and reversible
and in addition when we contract
components we're going to be tagging the
vertices with some sort of data that
represents the previous component such
that we don't lose too much information
we still want to be able to solve the
initial problem on the initial tree
um and the condition here is that that
data that we require
must be space efficient and that's what
space efficient means kind of depends on
your model of computation
okay so
tree contractions have been applied to a
number of applications including circuit
evaluation finding planar graph
separators approximating true width and
many more um there's a lot of literature
on this um it's a very widely usable
tool
so tree contractions were first
introduced in 1985 by miller and rafe
they used the pram model of computation
which is parallel random access memory
uh the gist of that for those of you
don't know is basically you have a bunch
of little processors doing independent
like operations and you're interested in
how long the process takes and they're
about to communicate like all the time
basically
um so they showed that their algorithm
requires o of log n prime time and this
has been improved over the years um but
we still have uh the o of log n time
requirement on those algorithms
let's just talk briefly about how tree
contractions work
they
go over a number of phases and in each
phase they have two stages so the first
stage is going to be compress in
compressed you're going to contract some
number of internal connected components
that you identify so for instance in
miller and rape algorithm they would
look at long chains of vertices with
only one child and contract every other
vertex into its parent so on the tree
example i have here that would look
something like this
the next stage is going to be rake where
we just contract all leads into their
parents and that's going to look
something like this
um so again o log n time hasn't been
broken since 1985. we're going to be
looking at a different model computation
computation where we can break this
complexity barrier in fact by a very
significant margin however i will note
that we're looking at round complexity
and a distributed model of computation
which is not 100 analogous to time
complexity but they are very similar and
they kind of translate between models
and interesting ways
so let's take a look at the model of
computation we'll be using adaptive
massively parallel computation um or
ampc for those of you who don't know
ampc is the successor to mpc which is a
popular model of computation
that's been used over the past decade
ampc was introduced a few years ago so
it's a very new area um
it's been shown to be able to solve some
things we don't think that mpc can do
it's strictly stronger than mpc and it
also is still highly practical it can be
implemented on existing systems so in
ampc we have this notion of a
distributed hash table which is just a
large data structure that you have
simultaneous you know parallel read acts
read and write access to um but it's
like restricted in specific ways you'll
see in a second ampc computation
proceeds in rounds in each round you
have a number of processors executing
local computations they are allowed to
read from the previous distributed hash
table and write to the next one um so
obviously in a round no messages can be
passed between machines this proceeds
over some number of rounds the input to
the problem is stored on the first
distributed hash table and the output
must be found on the final one so this
is how it works it machines aren't
associated with vertices or anything but
oftentimes you will associate them with
vertices
the complexity of interest is here is
the round complexity which can be
thought of as a lo a measurement of the
number of times that machines can
communicate i.e a machine can only send
a message between from it to another
machine in like between rounds
um we're also interested in some space
complexities we specifically use the low
memory model of computation where we
only have o of n to the one n to the
epsilon um space per machine for epsilon
between zero and one that's a highly
restrictive regime um because you can't
even store the neighborhood of a vertex
for some vertices and the total memory
must just not
blow up so it must be linear in the
problem size at any given time
okay so that's a high level of ampc
uh let's talk about some existing ampc
algorithms some of which we'll use and
some of it will compare our results to
so we're going to use a number of
existing algorithms executing processes
on forests
um these all have been shown to require
only o of one over eps on ampc rounds
this is highly efficient because we
generally assume epsilon is a constant
at least with respect to n we still want
to optimize in terms of epsilon but it's
much smaller than any dependency on n
it is conjectured that these require
omega of log n mpc rounds and that's why
we use ampc
our results are the following two
algorithms which are both both execute
three contractions the first is on trees
of bounded degree that is max degree n
to the epsilon
um and it only requires over one of our
epsilon squared rounds and this can be
used as a sub routine for our general
algorithm which requires oh that one
over epsilon cubed rounds
okay so those are two like main general
results but we also show a number of
applications and let's compare them to
some existing ampc algorithms so first
we show that our first algorithm
on bounded degree trees can actually be
used to solve some general problems so
maximal matching and maximal independent
set on general trees can be transformed
into problems on
bounded degree trees so we can apply our
more efficient algorithm to them and get
constant round algorithms however there
do exist algorithms already that um
solve maxwell matching an independent
set in one rounds and ampc so we don't
beat this um however we think this is an
interesting tool moving forward
in addition we look at maximum weighted
and cardinality matching which we both
both of them we can solve in o of one
over epsilon cubed rounds on trees this
beats o of log log n rounds from
previous algorithms also note that we
get a much better approximation for
maximum weight matching again the caveat
here is that these are only on treats
and then some previously unexplored
problems maximum weighted independent
set and tree isomorphism can also be
solved in oh one of our epsilon cubed
rounds on trees
okay
so
um i'm going to quickly go over some of
our algorithms so let's start with our
algorithm on bounded degree trees recall
that tree contractions requires two
stages compress and break and let's talk
about compress first we're to compress
according to what we call the pre-order
decomposition which is a partition of
vertices um such that each group in the
partition
the order of the groups in the partition
agrees with the pre-order traversal of
the vertices
additionally we have a bound on the sum
of the degrees of the vertices in each
part each group
which just will help us with our space
constraints
to compress we contract connected
components induced by each group
so we can see this an example of this
process here where vertices are labeled
with their groups note that this may
seem difficult to deal with because for
instance group two in this case is not
reduced at all we have three isolated
vertices start and three isolated
vertices to end however we can show some
nice properties of this process
first as long as the max degree of the
tree is bounded as we've talked about we
can find a period of decomposition with
only o of n to the one minus epsilon
groups
additionally because of the properties
of the pre-order traversal we can argue
that there's at most one internal node
per group
um and you can see that at least in this
example
so given these two properties we can
show that there are most k internal
nodes and k is at most o of n to the one
minus epsilon so when we rake we end up
with a tree that is just the thought the
the vertices in the tree are just the
internal nodes that occurred after we
compressed therefore the resulting tree
has only size of n to the one minus
epsilon thus we can complete this in o
of one over epsilon phases
um each phase we have to do a period of
traversal which is all of one over
epsilon rounds so we get a one over
epsilon squared algorithm
so that's our first result the second
result it actually kind of follows a
similar model so to compress we start by
getting rid of high degree vertices
because those are annoying
second we're going to take all of the
remaining trees in this forest we
created which are all low degree and
apply our previous algorithm therefore
each tree in the forest is contracted
into a single vertex then we simply add
the high degree vertices back in
and that's going to look something like
this
we get some nice properties for instance
no small component is going to be the
parent of another small component and
that's just by maximality of the
connected components and this is a key
feature that allows us to argue that
after compression at most an o of n to
the one minus epsilon fraction of
vertices are internal nodes
so this actually leads to the exact same
argument we had before o of n to the one
minus epsilon internal nodes uh we rake
all the leaves away so we get an o of n
to the one minus epsilon vertex tree
um so we take only one of our epsilon
phases since we apply our previous
algorithm each time we compress
we end up with an o of one over epsilon
cubed algorithm so it's just like
the nice a nice process that like worked
out quite like interestingly um there's
obviously a lot of complexity that gets
added when you also go to a apply this
to real applications there's still a lot
to show for specific applications
but i'll have to defer that to the paper
so i'd like to thank my co-authors and
as well as
the people organizing
itcs
thank you
wonderful thanks a lot
uh anybody have a quick question
i have quick two quick questions
one is can you give a pointer to the
conjecture of logan in the
standard mpc model or maybe write it in
chat it's called the one versus two
cycle conjectures yes okay so so this is
the same okay then you got that okay
cool
okay the other one does this model make
sense in a deterministic way
does this model make sense in a
deterministic way as in candidates
yes
it is you develop deterministic
algorithms on for ampc
okay so um
i think much of the existing algorithms
use random procedures so there's a lot
of like little things you have to do in
mpc and ampc that you kind of like
gloss over when you talk about higher
level algorithms like methods to like
ensure the right input gets the right
machine i kind of forget if those
require random processes if they do
require random process processes then a
lot of basic operations that you want to
do you can't do
um
otherwise this works i think these work
like i just wonder about the hash tables
and
the distributed hash tables
i am not familiar with the
implementation of distributed hash
tables so i do not know i would expect
they require some sort of randomness
to work properly
um
okay so uh i um i do see one question in
the chat by nicole i know we're over
time for the session but i don't i think
whoever wants to stay um can stay for
this question nicole do you want to ask
your question
i can also read it here um so the
question is have trees contractions
found uses for classes of crafts more
general than trees egg graphs of bounded
arbitrary um so the answer would be yes
on graphs of bounded tree with so you
can actually use the original tree
contraction algorithm in pram to find
actual actually a tree decomposition for
bath
graphs of bounded tree with and then you
can just apply the algorithm on top of
that it's still like something that you
need to
like
there's other things that are involved
in that algorithm so i can't just say
that we can use these algorithms that
way um about adversity maybe there's
some nice decomposition you get with
bounded arboricity graphs but um i don't
know i don't think i i haven't witnessed
like the original algorithms being used
for bounded diversity graphs but there
might be some literature out there
very nice all right uh thanks to all the
speakers in the session
and see you in the remaining sessions of
itcs
you